[موسيقى]
بالنسبه للوضع في تونس هناك تراكمات حدثت
يعني ما قبل
اربعه ايام 2011 وخاصه في العشريه الاخيره
يعني شهدت البلاد يعني عده ازمات وعدت
تقلبات الشعب التونسي وبالتالي
فما ينتظره الشعب التونسي هو استقرار
الحياه السياسيه
ونمو المسار الاقتصادي واستقرار الحياه
الاجتماعيه وبالتالي
فان على الوظيفه التنفيذيه وكذلك البرلمان
الاهتمام بكل ما من شانه ان يصلح
عديد من مثل يعني
تعليم مثل الصحه العموميه مثل النقل مثل
القضاء يعني على البيروقراطيه الاداريه
مثل يعني الاهتمام بالنواحي الاقتصاديه بث
التمانينه لدى افراد الشعب التونسي المهم
وانه بخلاصه القول انه في الماضي
استشرت يعني ثقافه الياس في البلاد واليوم
على البرلمان الحالي وكذلك الوظيفه
التنفيذيه العمل على استبدال ثقافه الياس
بثقافه الامل
[موسيقى]
نحن والحمد لله يعني حافظنا على حريه
التعبير وحريه اجتماع وحريه الاحتجاج
وكل يعني جهه سياسيه سواء يعني منظمه وحزب
يستطيعون العمل يعني بكل حريه في البلاد
ودليل على ذلك ان الاعلام يعني حر وكذلك
هناك يعني مظاهرات واحتجاجات
وسمح لها
بالتواجد
وظهور الاعلامي وبالتالي يعني من له هذا
الراي بطبيعه الحال هو حر في
[موسيقى]
لكن ما يلاحظ ان هؤلاء لم يجدوا التجاوب
الشعبي الكافي بل على العكس من ذلك لا
زالت يعني
مسجد المصداقيه
واضحه بالنسبه لمسار 25 جويليه والتي
تدابير 25 جويليه وما ثلاثه من اجراءات
دليل على ذلك ان يعني الشعب ينتظر اصلاحات
حقيقيه
[موسيقى]